[Music]
it is time now for CBS deals and this
morning we have a few items that could
help you get through the summer days and
summer nights and all an exclusive
discounts to start shopping now scan the
QR code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com a lifestyle expert Ashley
Bellman joins us with more good morning
good morning happy Memorial Day weekend
we made it it's now all summer long
cbsdeals.com go because we are bringing
you really really cool Brands I know
items starting with this Aqua Vault okay
so this is so cool this is a portable
safe so you go to the beach you know
sometimes you just kind of hide your
phone somewhere and hope that when you
go in the ocean you're going to come
back and it's still there you can
actually be protected you can hook this
onto your chair three-digit code you can
change it you can put cash in there put
your cards in there everything's safe
brilliant also have this phone case so I
can know I could bring it in the ocean I
could take some pictures I could go
poolside my phone
I can take pictures in the pool great
deal starting at 24.95 today 29 off oh
how about that what's next okay so this
I feel was made for me this is Magic
Mesh oh you're wearing my child around
I'm not gonna love it and this is a bug
two in one bug zapper so I am the person
sitting around the campfire that will
get bitten when no one else does so I
love the fact that now I could go to the
lake hold this up and those bugs those
pesky mosquitoes they're out or I just
put it on the table and use it as a
stationary zapper oh and they'll fly in
They're Gonna Fly I love it it's not
going to attract the mosquitoes which I
love so under 20. 17.99 40 off to allow
me to go to my husband's lake house and
not get bit five million times Cindy's
looking to be like you're crazy but this
is what I really this is like okay we
have a lot here this is very exciting so
Puma Cobra by volition America so the
brand Puma Cobra obviously great golf
clubs golf pros Kyle Westmoreland we
have
um who else Gary Woodland switched over
entirely to this brand because the
performance is there but volition
America they do such a beautiful job
changing them up making them their own
and also it's giving back and Memorial
Day weekend is the time to do that so
they have donated their Pro proceeds go
to the folding Flags Foundation they
have given 220 million dollars forty
four thousand dollars in scholarships
two families of Fallen Soldiers wow so
that's what Memorial Day is all about
and it's nice to know that you're a
shopping brand that's giving back well
clearly we aren't golfers we're not but
you know what I'm trying to learn my
brother's a golfer he tried to swipe
this because there's always
oh yeah
and a new Putter and a new golf bag the
deals are great up to 16 off today 299
is what the deals start at and they look
really cool so this looks like a fighter
jet and I and I love this yeah I just
love the we call these mittens right yes
nice little mittens right and then okay
so if maybe you're like us and you are
observing this or you need a chair so
creative outdoor makes these really
great chairs me and my husband stumbled
upon this really cute concert in the
park yesterday I'm like run back get the
chairs they fold up easily they sit down
easily yours rocks that's the director
chair
103.50 this one is 96. 25 off today
always I always have these in the garage
if I have guests over and I mean I can
just do some light reading a little
rocking chair nice oh I love this puppy
lots of uh drink options lots of uh
there's a cooler on the side of yours
there's spaces for your books for your
magazines I love that my I love the
cream the backyard
thank you so much of course we partner
with all of these companies to get great
deals so to buy anything you saw today
just scan that QR code on your screen or
head on over to cbsdeals.com